NOSE AT BOTH NATIONS AND RAMPING
UP HIS THREATS.
THE MYSTERIOUS UNDERGROUND
MOUNTAIN SITE WHERE KIM JONG-UN
TESTS HIS NUCLEAR BOMBS, TWO
U.S. OFFICIALS TELL CNN SPY
SATELLITES HAVE DETECTED NEW
ACTIVITY THERE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN SEVERAL WEEKS.
THE OFFICIALS SAY THERE APPEAR
TO BE MODIFICATIONS AROUND A KEY
TUNNEL ENTRANCE TO AN
UNDERGROUND TEST AREA.
>> IT WOULD LOOK LIKE THEY'RE
PREPARING FOR ANOTHER NUCLEAR
TEST.
THE TEMPO HAS INCREASED THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
>> Reporter: U.S. OFFICIALS SAY
MILITARY OPTIONS FOR NORTH KOREA
HAVE BEEN UPDATED AND WILL BE
PRESENTED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP IF
KIM'S REGIME CONDUCTS ANOTHER
NUCLEAR TEST, BUT IT IS NOT
CLEAR IF THE U.S. WOULD RESPOND
MILITARILY.
TONIGHT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
IS BLASTING KIM FOR ACTING LIKE
A MAFIA DON TO PAY FOR HIS
WEAPONS.
>> WHETHER IT IS MONEY
LAUNDERING OR MALICIOUS CYBER
ACTIVITY, NORTH KOREA HAS
ENGAGED IN A NUMBER OF CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISES THAT HELP FUND ITS
WEAPONS PROGRAMS.
>> NORTH KOREAN DIPLOMATS AROUND
THE WORLD HAVE ENGAGED IN AVA
RIGHT OF FRANKLY ILLEGAL
BEHAVIOR UNDER THE PROTECTION OF
DIPLOMATIC COVER, EVERYTHING
FROM DRUG TRADE,
METHAMPHETAMINES, TO PASSING
HIGH QUALITY COUNTERFEIT HUNDRED
DOLLAR BILLS.
>> Reporter: HE EVEN TRAFFICS IN
ENDANGERED SPECIES.
THE U.S. TREASURY DEPARTMENT
SAYS KIM'S INNER CIRCLE MANAGES
IT ALL THROUGH A SECRET BUREAU
CALLED OFFICE 39.
>> IT IS AN ELEMENT THAT KIM AND
HIS FATHER BEFORE HIM USED TO
ENSURE THAT THE ELITES ARE LOYAL
TO THE REGIME AND DO THAT
THROUGH ILLICIT ACTIVITIES.
THEY DO THAT LIKELY BY HAVING
MONEY STASHED OVERSEAS.
>> Reporter: EXPERTS SAY KIM
ALSO SPENDS THE MONEY ON LUXURY
GOODS FOR HIMSELF, FOR HIS
GLAMOR CONSCIOUS WIFE AND HIS
CRONIES.
THAT LONG MERCEDES LIMOUSINE
HE'S OFTEN SEEN STEPPING OUT OF,
A PRIVATE JET, AN EXCLUSIVE SKI
RESORT, AND A POLISHED WHITE
YACHT.
>> THIS IS KIM JONG-UN'S YACHT
WHICH HAS BEEN FEATURED SEVERAL
TIME IN THE NORTH KOREA MEDIA
USING PICTURES OF THE WINDOWS
FROM THIS PHOTO WE WERE ABLE TO
MATCH IT WITH THE PRINCESS YACHT
WHICH RETAILS FOR ABOUT $7
MILLION.
KIM JONG-UN KEEPS THIS YACHT IN
A BOATHOUSE AT HIS FAMILY
COMPOUND ON NORTH KOREA'S EAST
COAST IN THE PRO VINGS CAPITAL
CITY OF WAN SAN.
>> Reporter: POLICE BELIEVE
FORMER NBA STAR DENNIS RODMAN
WENT ON THAT YACHT ON ONE OF HIS
TRIPS TO NORTH KOREA.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CHOKE OFF THE
CASH FLOW TO FINANCE THOSE
WEAPONS.
SECRETARY OF STATE REX TILLERSON
IS